how is everyone doing today it's Matt
from code Tecna toriel's today I want to
walk you through how to make a first
person character in unreal you can use
the starter one for the first person
controller and it just gives you one but
what if you want to know how to do it on
your own that way you understand how to
edit it and stuff so that's sort of the
point of me doing this little tutorial
this is one of the first things I wanted
to learn when I jumped into unreal and I
figured it out so I can show you all the
steps to get a first person controller
going now I've got a few little random
things here but I'm gonna start a new
project that way I can show you from the
blank state and I'm just gonna leave it
all pretty much default here we'll call
this FPS demo so this is the point of
doing it from a blinks state is so that
you can follow along from any any
current state that your project is in
this will work in general to get a first
person character going so this is the
blank state got a little fly around if
we hit play gives us like a just a cam
that moves wherever we can't go through
stuff so if you want to make this your
own first-person little guy what you do
is you go down here to your content and
you're right click and make a new
blueprint then people in then click
character and let's I'm just going to go
with the standard and call it VP fps
character now when we double-click on
this we get the editor for this
blueprint and I'm going to drag it up
here along with the other windows
because it's how I like to do it so in
here we have some tabs we have a
viewport where we can do stuff with the
meshes and colliders for that and an
event graph which we're gonna use in
place of programming optionally you can
do C++ programming we'll be adding our
controls in this event graph but first
the way unreal works is well let's go
- or other Tavi or made one you gotta
set up your key bindings in the setting
so you don't have to do this but this is
kind of the standard for your main
character so you go to settings and then
I went to project settings and then
scroll down to input which is under
engine you know when you get here
you'll find this first area bindings
then you want to go ahead and set up
access mappings so you hit the plus
we're gonna do a couple more so so this
one's gonna be these axes mappings are
gonna be from moving around so let's
have move forward and the key for this
is going to be W and this scale is a 1.0
and then we're gonna have let's see we
don't actually hold on
we'll do it one at a time so on the move
forward I'll hit another plus and I'm
gonna put another key on move forward
and that will be s the backwards key and
collapse these it's on a keyboard
looking for ass there it is and we'll
just give that a negative 1.0 scale so
that will handle our move forward and
backwards so let's add another one for a
move right move right and this one is
going to be the D key there it is and we
also want to add a a before move left
there's a and that'll be negative one
dohno scale okay so now move forward we
can access with W or s Cena gives us
these different scales so this is just
the standard lost of movement and we're
also going to go ahead and prep this
with a boost we want to boost key like
shift so we'll just do shift
lap shift and we're gonna do plus here
and do a jump that will make that space
bar and that should be good for now
except of course we won't look will say
look vertical call us whatever you want
let's add another axis one for the
horizontal and we'll map this to the
mouse X on the vertical or I'm sorry
Mouse y on the vertical right up and
this will basically be up-and-down
horizontal will be the yaw left and
right so it'll be the mouse X there we
go and we're looking pretty good here so
this is auto saved as you enter them so
you can just close it and now we can go
back to our blueprint and in our
blueprint will now have access to those
keys so we'll go down here and we'll
right-click and search for move forward
there it is an axis event you can also
get an X's value we're looking for the
event in this case cuz we're gonna
handle the button presses so we'll drag
off this and we'll just put a move
character I think is what it's called
movement yeah I think this is an ADD
movement input okay so we'll do the axis
value for the axis values gonna go to
scale value but the world direction is
gonna be you go the way we're looking so
we're gonna get so we want its get actor
forward vector fairness that's this
current actor and ring out target itself
so yep that's the one and this will move
us forward so this is the move forward
this will also move us backwards because
if they press s it'll
but the negative scale value and they
remove this backwards okay let's do the
move right so on this they're also going
to do well we can copy this paste it
same thing add movement and this time
we're going to get actor write vector so
we want to add this to the right vector
there we go then we can highlight all
this with a box select you can do a
right click and create comment then
we'll just say move forward slash
backwards here and on this one we'll do
move left right okay so there's a few
more things we still got to do here and
let's go back to our map we want to be
able to test this movement but currently
we're still you learn a little default
guy so it's not the same one and it's
doing its own thing so what we got to do
here is basically just drag this guy in
and and then we got to go do something
with our game mode I think it's world
settings yeah settings world settings so
we got to pick a game mode or make some
game mode so we'll do a new blueprint
game mode base we'll just call it VP
I'll call it debug game mode that's just
like a test one and we basically just
want to go look at this I'll save it
it's fine you might not even need to
open it so so these tabs at the top are
important to get used to working with
it's kind of like the bread and butter
of this editor okay so the game mode we
want to just set this as the default one
there is and we want to set the default
pawn as the one we made here it is BP
fps character we want to set it to that
and now if we play we should have our
guy under control and we do
so it doesn't let me look with the mouse
and moving the mouse and he can tell but
I hit left I go left right could write
straight to go forward and I'm falling
off the world okay so forward I'm
running into something okay I'm falling
off the world there's some invisible
thing in front of me I think it might be
the other player the invisible player
okay so if I put me way up in the air I
should fall and I've got some kind of
bad sighs I don't know what that's about
the player start is bad sighs okay what
is this then this is my actual player so
let's hit play and yeah it drops all
right well the movement works the left
right forward back there's something I'm
colliding with them anyway so let's go
back into the blueprint character and
let's add the mouse look so just make
sure you get this right so we want to
handle the events look horizontal and
look vertical and we can do add
controller y'all for the horizontal and
the values just going to be the axis
value unless one will add pitch and
controller pitch input the target is the
value and that's really all we need to
do let's give it a test we'll hit
compile save play and now we can look
around with our mouse okay it's a little
wonky it's actually backwards on the up
and down it feels like I'm flying an
airplane
so I'm actually I think I just did it
wrong anything controls cuz let's go
let's go back to the settings project
settings and input and we'll see the
this look vertical mouse Y I'm going to
put it to a negative one and there we go
now when we hit play it kind of works
more
expected yes not him alright so there we
go that's all it takes to get the look
working correctly we'll just put look
there and now what else do we when we
had boost and jump those are pretty
important in standard and FPS games so
let's go ahead and do jump we'll get
that jump action key extra inch jump
that we made in the settings and when
you press it well I guess we just want
to jump so there is a default key called
just jump or a default thing in here
called jump and it applies some standard
jump so if I hit play here now spacebar
jumps and you can see it's just like the
default jump I'm not gonna go over how
to configure it because I haven't played
around with that myself actually this
one seems pretty sufficient for standard
cases and you can tell this is a funny
thing but you can tell I was like
testing this out playing with it this is
a jump that pub she uses I'm pretty sure
because you can do that hop skip
backwards thing with it and everything
so we'll just create a comment for this
pretty simple jump and now boost gets a
little more complicated I want to say
because like how much do you want to
boost by it's the thing you can hold
variables for that and you do those over
here you just make variables and then
you can access them and do stuff but I
just want to say well it works offset
max walk speed so there's this max walk
speed and if we do set max walk we do a
set max walk speed
apparently it sets your falling speed
too so there's probably gonna be a
little more involved with this in the
long run than just setting the max walk
speed which I'm not even seeing pop up
here oh oh I know what I do I gotta do I
gotta go character movement I remember
this this is so weird you do kick get
character movement then you drag from
this and then on this you have set max
walk speed so that's how you have to do
it here in unreal
it seems like 900 feels pretty good I'm
not sure how these scales work but I
it's like hard to tell the difference
between like 1 and 900 it seems like but
then once you get over a thousand
something else happens or I don't know
don't take don't quote me on that I was
looking I was trying to figure it out I
don't understand how the max walk speed
works it seems weird it seems like 1,200
to 1,300 is a good run speed or even up
to 2009 hundred or so seems like a good
walk speed but play around with your own
numbers let me know if you figure out
more in the comments below because I
don't know thanks going on man like okay
here's the code for the character
movement component so we could just dig
in and C++ code I'm not gonna do that
right now and I wanted to do that so
when we press boost all this goes into
here and there we go that's all we need
to do and then when we release it we
want to do this similar thing well I
guess we can just copy this right
paste it and here we go so when they
release it we'll set our speed back to
1000 so I got a 1000 of 2000 should get
about a 2x boost we'll go ahead and play
this normal walks so hard to tell in a
small small map let me just increase the
size of this a bit well we'll make this
one we'll just delete this one make this
one massive yeah there we go all right
so we got a bigger area and now we can
walk and then if I hold shift you can
tell there is a bit of speed up so that
is working see what else did I want to
show you I don't know what this bad size
is if someone knows let me know but in
general this will work this will allow
you to edit further there's there's a
really basic boost so what I did in my
other one I'll just drag this over I
don't want to do
again I had a two variables added
default walk speed and a run multiplier
and then on the event begin play
I set the run multiplier to X set the
default walk speed to 900 so when they
run it to X's and I just have that logic
in here when they press it and times it
by the multiplier but you know you can
do it however you want ultimately this
is probably gonna come from like
character stats or whatever so this is
this was just my janky way of getting it
going to begin with but yeah so that's
how you do it that's how you get an FPS
character going I mean uh let me know
guys do you want to see more for these
tutorials boost do you know do you want
to see more unreal tutorials as I learn
stuff and should I just make these
videos and teach everybody it's not I
can do that
this is kind of fun there's one other
thing I wanted to show you guys but
maybe I'll talk about in the next
episode and just keep this one simple
and just you know getting that basic FPS
character going
I guess there's one more thing I should
mention about it on my way out don't
forget to Like comment subscribe and I'm
gonna go and ahead and show you how to
just move the camera here real quick on
our way out so I will click on the
viewport in our FPS camera click on
viewport I'm just gonna add a component
for the camera and remove this sucker up
a little bit and for the back you can
play around with it but basically you
can get this you know kind of to wear a
head would be on a human so now we're up
a little higher and the thing as soon as
you had a camera you knows you can't
look up and down anymore so that feels
weird right what you got to do is well
you got this camera clicked on you just
go over to the settings and there's a
setting to to move it
use pong controller rotations so once
you click that pile say they play again
now look you can look up and down again
and you're so your collider box is that
capsule below it it's gonna it's gonna
be a little smoother and well I'm gonna
leave it at that you can see though just
on your own that you can add mesh in
here for your player and go further with
it hope you enjoyed we'll see you guys
in the next video
and stay safe keep code Matthau